i'll tell you what happened with me and
desserts okay
so here's the thing i'll have it
like there'll be a dessert at the party
and i'll be like uh i'll have a little
you know but then here's the thing other
people come to the party late and they
bring another dessert
and you don't want to let them down
you know i don't want somebody to just
see me just look at their dessert and
walk off
you know like i'm some kind of
you know like i'm like a deadbeat dad
you know like i'm some kind of deadbeat
dessert dad you know who just looks at
his son and just walks off or moves away
moves to akron or you know moves to
you know norfolk
you know i want to be
you know i want to be that participant
and so if i see a dessert
and it looks
good enough you know i i have to stay
there and spend some time with it and
that's what happened to me today
i didn't plan on eating a lot of
desserts but next thing you know
somebody showed up with this and
somebody showed up with that
and then somebody you know
somebody put a bunch of animal crackers
in the oven and [ __ ] baked them and
they were already baked
but now they're hot animal crackers
my is rest and i'm guilty i'm about to
prosecute my stomach with about 30 of
them yatches
and i had some mississippi muds you know
this beautiful tall lady showed up with
a thing of mississippi mud
and i mean god dang that thing was i
mean this dessert container was probably
a foot deep i mean you could have got
stuck in there you could have lost a
friend in there if you had a small
friend
and so i had some of that and next thing
you know
i've only had about a little bit of
regular food you know maybe a small cut
of ham
you know i think i had a small cut of
ham
and then probably 19 desserts
and then i can't even feel my face
because i feel like my whole face is
just infested with sugar and
you know and then i just start not
feeling good and then i'm depressed and
i'm then i'm like changing into my
running clothes and everybody's like
relaxing because it's easter
and now i'm that freaking creep that's
going for a run on easter and it's just
you know sometimes when you get into
that
you know i get into that bermuda
triangle of desserts and it just can be
dark for me
it can be really really dark
so so
usually what i'll do is just decide you
know what today i'm gonna eat whatever
i'm just gonna go like that
and i wish we didn't even care about
what we ate
you know i think there was a long time
ago
probably back in the old days
you know out and now everybody's so
concerned about their diets everybody's
on a diet i'm on this you know i'm on
atkins i'm on jerry atkins you know i'm
i'm a senior you know i'm on uh keto
you know i'm on kato kaelin i'm on
you know only cheeseburgers during
murders you know everybody's on
something i'm on vegetables i'm on you
know broccolini you know i only only eat
by my stepmother's house my buddy told
me he's on that diet i'm like that's not
a [ __ ] diet i mean you're gonna
you're gonna starve you're an idiot
but everybody's on some type of diet
you know somebody's like i'm on you know
water and limes like ah that's not a
diet
you know that's somebody that's
you know probably gonna die on an island
you know so some of this stuff isn't die
isn't diets sorry there's a call came in
and
i have a ringtone of a teenager
uh but yeah everybody's on a diet
everybody's on something you know and
it's just but back in the old days you
didn't you weren't on a diet
if somebody shot an animal that's what
you ate
if somebody killed a um you know a
bushel of corn that's what you ate
somebody showed up with a
you know a little bit of labrador a
couple of labrador medallions that's
what you ate that was it
i mean there were probably years where
people were eating this or eating that
you know i'm not trying to be vile but
people were you know having german
shepherd for dinner
a long time ago in the 1700s
come on
you know people were having hay you know
a ham was you you killed a pig and
that's that was it somebody shoot a dove
or an owl
and that was it and that's what you ate
there wasn't an opportunity for all this
dieting
but now you know once we get you know we
get a little bit more sedentary and that
food starts to build up in us
so it's just a different time now and so
now you know we're a little bit more
concerned and we didn't have mirrors
back then that's another thing
maybe instead of dieting we just get rid
of all the mirrors
have we thought about that yet
i mean i sometimes i wish we could just
have a big mirror burning you know
everybody just shows up and throws a
damn mirror into a big
gorge
one of these empty gorges and just
throws a bunch of gasoline in there are
turpentine and lights that [ __ ] up
let's burn these mirrors so who knows
who's fat
who knows who who's out of shape who
knows who's feeling a little
you know if you lift your arm up and you
can't lift it up
or if you're underarm just
you know i got a buddy he's got his
underarms have kind of become tits under
his arm
and they still have all that hair on him
than underarm hair so he'll lift his arm
up and it's like this just hair tip kind
of pops out from under his arm
and i don't know why i don't know what's
going on with him
he's like i'm thinking i need a diet i'm
like i think you need a haircut on them
tits first
and go from there
but it's you know it's just
i before we were infected with all these
diets i think we used to enjoy our time
a little bit more and
i guess if i could look back on today a
little bit i probably wish i would have
not thought about
you know
calories and all of this and that as
much but i would have just been you know
more focused on the day
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy
two
options watch one this one or this one